So when we're determining conic sections, we want to look at the equation. We
can tell by the equation whether or not the shape will be a circle, an elipse,
a hyperbola, or a parabola. For the case of circles, they will always have the
same amount of x squared and y squared. Meaning the numbers in front of x
squared and the number in front of y squared will be the same. Even if I change
these to 2 I still have a shape of a circle. And changing into 5 I still have a
perfect circle. So let's go back to a perfect circle that has a radius of 10
units. We can change this equation to become an ellipse. All we need to do is
make the coefficients of x squared and y squared different. For example, if I
make this x squared term have a coefficient of four, instead of one, I get an
ellipse. The key idea for circles and ellipses is that there's a positive sign
in between the x squared term and the y squared term. The difference between
them is that circles have the same coefficient whereas ellipses, have different
coefficients. Here the coefficient of x squared is 4, and here the coefficient
of y squared is 1. We usually just don't list the 1. But notice it's the same
exact graph. Now if we want to turn this ellipse into a hyperbola. We'll want
to change this addition sign to subtraction. Hyperbolas will always have a
subtraction sign between their x squared term and their y squared term. So,
changing this to a minus, we get our hyperbola. Remember, the minus sign is
like the knife that cuts open our ellipse and inverts the sides so they point
outward. And since our x squared term comes first our hyperbola opens to the
left and to the right. They point in these directions. But let's see what
happens when we make the x squared term negative, and the y squared term
positive. We have subtraction between the squared terms, so we know this graph
will end up being a hyperbola. And look, it is. The only difference is that
now, our hyperbola opens up and it opens down. And that's because the y squared
term comes first, it's positive. Whereas, the x squared term is negative. Now,
there's one more conic to look at, the parabola. A parabola has x squared or y
squared, but it doesn't have both. So in order to change this hyperbola into a
parabola let's change y squared into just y. Now, I'm also going to change the
value 100 to 10, so that way we can see the graph on here. And notice, when we
change y squared to y, we get a parabola. The vertex is at zero negative 10,
and the parabola opens upward. And here's how you can tell if a parabola will
open up or if it'll open down. We can rearrange this equation and solve for y.
So first I'll subtract negative 4x squared from both sides of this equation.
This gives me negative y on the left, negative 4x squared on the right, and
positive 10 on the right. Next I'll multiply every term by negative 1. This
will give me 1y equals positive 4x squared minus 10. And we can easily see that
all three of these equations represent the same graph. I could graph this one
and I could graph this one and see that they all make the same parabola. Since
this parabola is y equals we know its going to open up. Or it's going to open
down. And since the coefficient on the squared term is positive, it opens up.
Now, if we make this coefficient negative, the parabola opens down. So, when
determining whether or not something opens up, or something opens down, you
want to solve for the single variable first, and then look at the coefficient
of the squared term. Is it positive or is it negative. So we've seen a parabola
open up and down but let's see one that opens left and right instead of having
the parabola be y equals let's make it be x equals so we'll make the x term be
a single x variable. And the y term be y squared. Doing that we see we get a
sideways parabola and it points to the right and again we know this parabola
opens to the right since we can rearrange this equation to be x equals. First
we'll add y squared to both sides so we'll get 4x equals positive y squared on
the right. And positive 10 on the right. Next we'll divide every term by 4, to
get x equals 1 fourth y squared plus 10 fourth. And when I graph each of these
equations, I should see that they're all the same. Since this parabola is in
the form x equals, we know it's going to open to the right or to the left. And
since this number, this coefficient is positive 1 fourth. Our graph opens to
the right. If instead we make it negative 1 fourth, our parabola will open to
the left. So remember y equal parabolas open up and down. And x equal parabolas
open right and left. The sign on the squared term tells us which direction that
is. Up and right for positive. Down and left for negative.